it's great to welcome to the program
today ken caldera who's a climate
scientist at the Carnegie Institution
for Sciences Department of global
ecology also professor by courtesy in
the Stanford University Department of
Earth System science we've been talking
Ken about many different aspects of how
the climate on our planet is changing
and one of those that I've mentioned a
few times now is the acidification of
our oceans let's start with what that
means and why this is a relevant area of
study when we think about climate change
when we burn coal or gas we release
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere but
over time most of that carbon dioxide
will get absorbed by the ocean and this
is a problem because when carbon dioxide
reacts with sea water becomes carbonic
acid and in high enough concentrations
the carbonic acid can dissolve the
shells and skeletons of marine organisms
and even in the lower concentrations
that we're expecting this century it can
make it more difficult for marine
organisms to grow their shells and
skeletons and this is likely to be
devastating for some marine ecosystems
and we're unsure what what it will do to
other marine ecosystems
what's our basis for measurement in
other words if we say well the oceans
are more acidic how is that measured
sort of what's the scale and how much of
a change are we seeing in terms of the
the the level of acidity scientists
measure something called pH which is a
measure of the hydrogen ion
concentration or activity in the ocean
and and so what's really important is
how much the different chemical species
are changing especially the building
blocks with which marine organisms build
their shells and skeletons and so since
the pre-industrial time so before the
Industrial Revolution that may be the
concentration of hydrogen ions has gone
up something like 30% and and this would
means also that some of the building
blocks that marine organisms that build
their shells and skeletons have gone
down by 30% but
more or less it goes opposite to the
amount of co2 in the atmosphere so if
atmospheric co2 doubles some of the
essential building blocks that marine
organisms need need to build their
shells gets cut in half and and this is
going to have big impacts especially for
coral reefs and other ecosystems that
depend on these sort of hard bony
structures yeah and before we dig more
into that just to get to to get this
talking point out of the way before we
go further what if somebody hears you
say compared to the pre-industrial
revolution and they say well the tools
we had then are nothing like the tools
we have now for doing this kind of
science how do we know what the levels
were prior to the Industrial Revolution
the answer is what the yes as you point
out the the biological effects are
uncertain but the chemical effects are
well known and that's because you you we
do things with fancy models but you
don't need fancy models you could take a
bucket of seawater and put it under a
bell jar and change the co2
concentrations in of the overlined gases
in that bell jar and then look at the
chemistry of the seawater and see how it
changes and so the the chemistry of how
carbon dioxide affects seawater is
extremely well understood and there are
a number indicators of what chemistry
were in the past we can see where shells
were forming in the past but the main
thing is you don't need any fancy models
you can just put a bucket of seawater
under different concentrations of co2
and see how the chemistry changes so the
the chemical changes are well understood
and well known but the biological
effects are highly uncertain in many
cases so let's talk through now the sort
of successive impact on the ecosystem
the the water becomes more acidic this
impact as you've mentioned all sorts of
coral reefs significantly but also I if
I understand correctly crustaceans and
other sea life as well yes I have a
postdoc working with me who's looking at
how
ocean acidification affects the larval
stages of sea urchins and it inhibits
their growth similar experiments have
been done on moister larvae and and many
other marine organisms
it seems that often it's the larval
stages that are most sensitive because
if you think of adults are better able
to control their environment but these
little larvae with just a few cells in
them are very sensitive to changes in
ocean chemistry and their that's when
they're needing to build their a lot of
their hard bony parts and they're having
more trouble doing it and in more acidic
oceans and what would be some of the
possible subsequent effects of this on
the broader ocean ecosystem and then
even of the entire planet a lot of my
study has been focused on coral reefs
and that's kind of the easiest system to
understand what's going on because one
type of organism builds the very
architecture of that ecosystem and we
know that if hard stony corals disappear
that coral reef ecosystem is going to
disappear so we've done experiments
showing that ocean chemistry influences
the rate at which the corals can grow
their skeletons and if we project
forward from our experiments we would
can conclude that sometime in a few
decades nearly all the coral reefs in
the world are likely to be in a net
eroding losing mass and once those coral
reefs lose enough of that calcium
carbonate stony material the reef won't
be able to survive now you know we know
we've also done work along the
California coastal system and we know
that the larvae of many of the marine
organisms that live along the California
coast are sensitive to ocean
acidification but it's a very
complicated ecosystem and it's unknown
if you start toying with creatures near
the base of the food chain how is that
going to affect the entire ecosystem
it's impossible to conduct a real
bearment on that and so you know I think
we can expect that big changes will come
but but exactly what those changes will
be are hard to predict you've talked a
little bit about sort of what may be
solutions or mitigating activities might
be for this problem what one of the
things I've seen you say would not be
particularly useful at least as far as
ocean acidification is concerned is sort
of solar geoengineering right we
sometimes hear about reflecting some
portion of sunlight back into space to
counteract warming of the earth but that
you've said specifically with the issue
you study wouldn't really make a
difference because you're talking about
co2 content on earth right yes
carbon dioxide has both chemical effects
and physical effects on Earth's
radiation balance or Earth's climate
system and so even if you could somehow
correct the climate effects of carbon
dioxide we'd still be stuck with the
chemical effects now we did on a small
patch of reef do an experiment where we
threw an antacid into the seawater and
and neutralized some of that carbon
acidity and showed that the coral reef
grew faster under those circumstances
but this would be impractical to do at a
huge scale so I could imagine somebody
trying to protect a little Marine
Sanctuary and a bay somewhere through
these kind of approaches and it would be
very expensive and difficult but to do
something the size of the Great Barrier
Reef I think it's just not feasible so
what are more feasible or at least
conceptually so ways that we could work
on this issue well there are two main
things we need to be doing one is we
need to be transforming our energy
system into one that does not rely on
using the sky and the oceans as a waste
dump for our carbon dioxide pollution
and so this means building you know
renewable energy systems and perhaps
nuclear systems and so on the other main
thing we need to do is try to relieve as
many
their stressors on marine ecosystems as
possible marine ecosystems are not only
subject to ocean acidification but also
as we pointed out to to global warming
coastal pollution overfishing pesticide
runoff and so on and so the more we can
relieve these other stressors on marine
systems the more resilient they're
likely to be to ocean acidification very
very important issue one we will also
touch on with Elizabeth Kolbert who is
going to be on the program who
interviewed you extensively it seems
like anyway for her yes the sixth
extinction she came with us son one of
our experiments to the coral reef in to
some coral reef in the Great Barrier
Reef and that's right Australia and it
was great to have her there absolutely
fascinating we've been speaking with Ken
caldera climate scientist at the
Carnegie Institution for Sciences
Department of global ecology ken thanks
a lot for talking to us today thank you
very much